[Music]
points of light glow like stars in a
black Sky The View draws back revealing
the lights glittering inside a piece of
a broken Crystal that glows blue as it
sits on a table with a pike mask a deck
of sabak cards and data discs
a creature's little hand reaches up and
swipes an oval object with a scaly black
surface off the table carrying the
object in its mouth the creature the
size of a small dog with three tendrils
on each side of its gecko-like face
brings it to a young woman kneeling to
the side of a doorway
good boy
she Pockets the object
I want that fighter strip for parts by
tomorrow the woman pierced through the
doorway all right
sneaks up on a guy just beyond the
doorway and punches him out
that worked she creeps behind stacked
crates toward two figures on a walkways
we take our credits now but let's stop
them from stabbing Us in the back the
young woman hides as one of the figures
walks away next various options toggle
on screen attack distract and press
which gets selected hit that button a
creature NYX dashes to a control panel
and jumps up to press a button a pulley
system starts to move carrying a large
crate across the walkway nice one
the young woman jumps on and Nick sleeps
onto her back hang on tight little buddy
she clings to the side of the crate as
it carries her over the facility full of
Starship Parks she drops onto the lowest
level near a Thruster and stays low as
she moves among the spare parts
a rhodian points a gun at her a subtitle
reads Hired Gun in hotties what are you
doing
I was just lost her the young woman
draws her own Blaster shooting down the
road again okay okay we'll figure this
out the young woman runs up a ramp as
explosions Rock the lowest level Red
emergency lights flash on the next floor
where an enemy activates a shield shield
an option appears blaster or focused
which selects she fires disabling the
shield and knocking out the enemy as
Blaster fire comes at her from multiple
directions she ducks behind a barrier
before firing back
hey Nick
she Fires at something near a TIE
fighter on a scaffolding platform
causing an explosion this is getting bad
she shoots onto the lower level where
two enemies firing at her take cover
she takes out one enemy and shoots at
the other an option appears pick up
let's try this out
she opens fire with a blaster rifle
causing an explosion that sends people
flying stink Ferrick
she tosses the spent rifle and runs for
an open dock throwing a cable onto a
mechanical arm the young woman lowers
herself out of the facility with niggs
on her back
I think that went pretty well right
still under Fire
and heads across Rocky terrain until she
outruns the attack racing over a plateau
she catches air finding two pursuers up
ahead
maneuvering between them the young woman
pulls a head on a dirt road
on the back of her bike NYX looks behind
them the pursuers overtake her then the
view slows as the young woman draws her
blaster
she fires on one pursuer then the second
causing him to crash into a rock
formation
that was close she hugs the dirt roads
curves 95 I got the package where are
you waiting for you and jaunt us hope
were you seen I said I got it what else
matters
I'll be working for the Pikes anytime
soon
um well they'll probably forgive me
the young woman steers around a writer
going in the opposite direction as she
heads toward a town
there's Johnson's hope we made it next
she drives beneath an arched entrance
with letters hanging from above parking
her bike she hops off and stares toward
a circular building text appears jonta's
hope toshara she waits for a speeder to
pass before crossing the road breaking
into a jog she goes by a Twilight woman
leaning against a post
[Music]
weathered doors slide open for the young
woman and Knicks to enter a dimly lit
Cantina where they approach a humanoid
Droid wearing a long coat at the bar
hey Andy
your late cake Doc is waiting what are
you worried no
no okay a bouncer stops them a subtitle
reads a bouncer in hot tease not the
Droid what
be careful
danka's a broker not a friend
can't be trusted who can out here
see you back at the ship
downstairs K passes through a beaded
curtain into a private area where a
hologram shows a fight Amman kalamari
wearing a popped collar and layers of
necklaces sits with an imperial officer
round two and I still like my odds her
companion nods toward K as she
approaches their tables
back already
I told you she's fresh but she's good
who's this
just a friend
join us okay sets down the black object
as she sits job was more complicated
than you said Danka
you lived Danka opens the object
revealing shifting mushroom-like plants
growing inside Nick's leans in close hey
he's on toys Nick's backs down and Danka
plucks one of the plants
they're Investments
the officer holds out her gloved hand
expectantly and Danka gives her the
plant then pays k
wait
Matt
don't really know many of you
[Music]
stealing illegal Contraband running with
syndicates I could say you're a threat
to the Empire
but I won't have to if you're smart two
options appear bribe or do not bribe the
latter is selected thanks but I'm smart
enough to get myself out of trouble you
pay the tax just like everyone else Kate
draws her Blaster let's just relax the
officer holds up a com link you won't
make a doctor shower alive
Maybe
backing away from the table K holsters
her weapon and strides through the
beaded curtain as she arrives back
upstairs Her Image appears on screens
throughout the establishment old
Troopers we
okay runs outside
could be I told you not to trust her
not the first time we've ever on the
Empire with Knicks running at her side
case prints up a ramp onto a landing pad
they hurry up a ship's open ramp and
once inside make a beeline for the
cockpit where nd5 waits in the
co-pilot's seat we need to leave yeah no
kidding
case sent to the Pilot's chair options
appear over the seat controls and
navigation computer
[Music]
the ship lifts off coasting clear of The
Landing Pad before accelerating in an
upward trajectory into the Cloudy Blue
Sky
the ship passes into a cloud the
thrusters glowing through the
surrounding Haze as the craft ascends
the haze clears as they leave the
atmosphere they arrive near disabled
ships and floating debris text breeds
toshara orbit toshara system
are we good nothing on the sensors yet
suddenly firing ships close in on them
anybody on the sensors now
near the wreckage of a ship cave fires
back
I feel inclined to remind you that we
should shape the Empire quickly thanks
I'm working on it okay flies through a
hole in a giant piece of the disabled
ship emerging in a thick debris field
another ship fires on them
K accelerates between two halves of
another large piece of wreckage for
cover as her ship coasts back into the
open an enemy vessel appears out of
hyperspace
[Music]
ship barrel rolls to the side to avoid a
blast let's jump
foreign
Stars stretch into streaks of light as
the ship makes the jump to hyperspace it
emerges near an asteroid field above a
gray Planet Akiva orbit a Kiva system
we made it
text appears Quest completed the broker
curving lines resembling parentheses
framing the ship center on the planet on
board Nix leans his front legs against K
seat and she invites him onto her lap he
hops up and she pets him she pulls one
of the plants out of her pocket and eyes
its bulbous purple top got your new toy
NYX happily holds it between his teeth
so where do we go next
anywhere we want
NYX jumps out of her lap and K pushes
the ship's throttle forward
Nick sleeps onto the back of the
captain's seat as they weave through the
asteroid field toward the planet seen
from behind he finds herself surrounded
and puts up her hands but draws her
Blaster as someone Fires at her
she Ducks into a doorway later she
fleeing and steps out to find an atst
towering over her various views follow K
through different environments including
a snowy Street an arid town and an
industrial facility with nd5 now Kay
sneaks through a hangar swarming with
Stormtroopers in a corridor she shoots
down a trooper then bashes into a second
a TIE fighter chases K's ship out of an
exploding Hangar Star Wars Outlaws come
in 2024.
Starwars outlaws.com
[Music]